I take great pride in the fact that I'm
a non-partisan foreign policy expert who
was served under three Republican and
Democratic presidents I have no interest
in advancing outcome of your inquiry in
any particular direction except toward
the truth I will not provide a long
narrative statement because I believe
that the interest of Congress and the
American people is best served by a but
allowing you to ask me your questions
based on questions and statements I have
heard some of you on this committee
appear to believe that Russia and its
security services did not conduct a
campaign against our country and that
perhaps somehow for some reason Ukraine
did this is a fictional narrative that
has been perpetrated and propagated by
the Russian security services themselves
the unfortunate truth is that Russia was
the foreign power that systematically
attacked our democratic institutions in
2016 this is the public conclusion of
our intelligence agencies confirmed in
bipartisan congressional reports it is
beyond dispute even if some of the
underlying details must remain
classified
the impacts of the successful 2016
Russian campaign remains evident today
our nation is being torn apart truth is
questioned our highly professional
expert career foreign service is being
undermined u.s. support for Ukraine
which continues to face armed aggression
aggression has been politicized the
Russian government's goal is to weaken
our country to diminish America's global
role and to neutralize a perceived u.s.
threat to Russian interests President
Putin and the Russian security services
aim to counter US foreign policy
objectives in Europe including in
Ukraine where Moscow wishes to reassert
political and economic dominance I say
this not as an alarmist but as a realist
I do not think long term conflict with
Russia's are the desirable or inevitable
I continue to believe that we need to
seek warez of stabilizing our
relationship with Moscow even as we
counter their efforts to harm us right
now Russia's security services and their
proxies have geared up to repeat their
interference in the 2020 election we are
running out of time to stop them and the
course of this investigation I would ask
you please not promote politically
driven falsehoods that so clearly
advanced Russian interests as
Republicans and Democrats have agreed
for decades Ukraine is a valued partner
of the United States and it plays an
important role in our national security
and as I told the committee last month I
refused to be part of an effort to
legitimize an alternate narrative that
the Ukrainian government is a u.s.
adversary and the Ukraine not Russia
attacked us in 2016 these frictions are
harmful even if they are deployed for
purely domestic political purposes
President Putin and the Russian security
services operate like a super PAC they
deploy millions of dollars to weaponize
our own political opposition research
and false narratives when we are
consumed by partisan rancor we cannot
come by combats
these external forces are there as there
seek to divide us against each other
degrade our institutions and destroy the
faith of the American people in our
democracy I respect the work that this
Congress does and carrying out its
constitutional responsibilities
including this require II and I'm here
to help you to the best of my ability if
the president or anyone else impedes or
subvert the national security of the
United States in order to further
domestic political or personal interests
that's more than worthy of your
attention but we must not let domestic
politics stop us from defending
ourselves against the foreign powers who
truly wishes harm and as you to answer
your questions thank you thank you dr.
hill will now proceed to the first round
of questions